you like it that way the country divided
full of hatred no vecten no not at all
our relationship with the European unis
changed it's a reason May had a deal
wasn't perfect but it would have
delivered brexit and what will this
extension achieve what is another three
months going to achieve here in London
it's still all about brexit Boris
Johnson has shut down a fractious and
angry Parliament but not before MPs
managed to do him serious damage denying
him a date for a next general election
and forcing him by law to seek another
brexit extension from the EU if he can't
get a deal by October the 19th my guest
here this week is Andrew Britton
Conservative MP and leading brexit
supporter will Boris Johnson now obey
the law that Parliament has put in front
of him
[Music]
andrew bridden welcome to conflict zone
one of the biggest obstacles preventing
a deal between Britain and the EU is the
Irish backstop the so called insurance
policy to keep her open border between
Northern Ireland and the Irish Republic
the government has promised new
proposals where are they well I think
they're already out there alternative
arrangements have been discussed for
over 12 months a trusted trader scheme
for regular trade it's a very out yet
relatively small amount of trade that
goes across the board about two and a
half billion pounds a year
yeah but exemption exemptions for small
traders and and checks away from the
border but August 21st the prime
minister said in Berlin standing beside
Angela Merkel you rightly say the onus
is on us to produce those solutions
he hasn't produced any since then why
not well I think to an extent the Irish
border issue is a conflated issue might
be before the Irish border became a
stick with which to beat the the UK
government during these negotiations
where the proposals are well the
proposals are and we're afterwards the
proposals are old proposals they were
out there a few months after the
referendum was a joint statement by the
head of HMRC Northern Ireland and
customs exercise south of the border
which said the current infrastructure on
the border was quite sufficient to deal
with any outcome said it isn't look the
minister is playing politics with this
issue isn't he he calls the backstop
anti-democratic let's not forget that he
actually voted for that backstop in the
withdrawal agreement in May just four
months ago the third time it was put out
to vote I didn't I didn't so did Dominic
rob so the leader of the house Jacob
Riis MOG leading light of your European
research group who said if we take this
deal we are legally out of the EU it
restores our independence that's what
you wanted for heaven's sake restoring
an independence if the backstop wasn't
so terrible four months ago why is it
terrible now I think they were looking
at the lesser of Evil's I think they
could see that brexit was slipping away
potentially and it was Teresa Mays deal
or no brakes
I didn't hold to that opinion the fact
was that treason may put a job on the
line and said if you if you back my
withdrawal agreement and get it through
I will stand down and let someone else
take over the the negotiations about the
future relationship I think that was a
flawed argument in my case people have
elastic principles one moment it's okay
then the next moment it's not I think
they're playing politics with it it's
not a matter of life support is it it is
for a large number of us I think that
probably Boris Johnson and Jacob Riis
MOG and obviously with hindsight they
will have regretted voting for the
withdrawal agreement to mv3
at the end of the day that was never a
deal that was ever it never got more
than 15% support by the public and they
didn't nobody let any price do you I
want I do want to remember rod the
minister who just resigned to ask for
reassurances that the government was
working on a deal she didn't get them
she directly contradicted the prime
minister's promised that he was a
hundred percent focused on getting a
deal absolutely but when contradicted
the updates I've been grateful to
receive had not provided me with the
assurances I saw I think amber rods
position on EU membership and the
withdrawal agreement and the
negotiations are well known and she
doesn't mean she's telling the lie does
it but she's telling it from her
perspective seen the papers
well she's seen the cabinet I suppose
she knows it's not happening but surely
anyone who's ever negotiated anything
Tim knows that with a walkaway position
the more you prepare for no deal and I
said this consistently over the last
three and half years the more the
government prepared for no deal and
publicly let that be known the less
likely we were ever going to need it
it is unfortunate that so much time was
wasted going down the blind alley of the
withdrawal agreement with all the
curries are may well come on to that in
the moon but with Boris Johnson's about
trust isn't it and he doesn't score
highly on that does he well this is the
man who announced in July that the EU
was stopping Britain from having free
ports we could do free ports he said it
would be a massive boost to this economy
we don't because of our membership of
the EU utter nonsense well if we
actually sign that we drove it we
actually would be giving away the power
/ state aid and those sort of tax
discounts we're giving a veto to the
European Union so my potentially talk
about three ports like that when that's
simply not true
well if we'd sign the withdraw agreement
we would have been under a veto on our
state aid rules mr. Brittain but we
wouldn't have known we would have had
three ports across the EU most of them
in new member countries what mr. Johnson
also didn't seem to know was that until
2012 when the legislation that
established free ports expired here in
Britain there were free port areas in
Liverpool Southampton Tilbury Sheerness
and Prestwick Airport but he didn't know
any of that so this is the kind of
nonsense that comes from the government
there's a distance I think there's a
difference between the EU allowing us to
have a free port when we're a fully
functioning member of the European Union
and once we were in the withdrawal
agreement if we asked for a free port or
they had a veto he was not necessarily
in the EU interest to allow us to have
that advantage according to a House of
Commons library if the Treasury wants to
designate three ports you can do it by
statutory instrument there's no need for
a vote it can do it just like that in
five minutes so there's nothing to do
with you as I come back to the point if
we've signed the withdrawal agreement
we've given the EU a veto on all of our
state aid rules including the provision
of free ports and our relationship with
the European has changed it's not the
same as it was five years before the
referendum it'll never be the same again
whatever the outcome of the brexit
negotiations is what it'll be different
it'll be different yes that's what we
promise the people that I would leave
like Boris Johnson you two in the past
have seemed strangely baffled about EU
rules and you you told an Irish radio
station last year that it was possible
under the common travel area
arrangements between Britain and Ireland
for Britain's to get passports in
Ireland and the Irish to come over here
and get Passport they can't I mean that
was simply wrong even what it was it was
a it why did you put out this stuff well
it was an unfortunate situation I
shouldn't have done the interview the
interview was after midnight and it was
two or three days after my wife had just
given birth to us I was a little sleep
deprived and a little demob happy at
that stage I shouldn't have given the
interview I mistook that for the
situation regarding two people in
Northern Ireland who have the choice of
taking either a British or an
if passport and I have apologized for
that mistake your suggestions that under
an obscure World Trade Organization
statute article 24 Britain can somehow
avoid tariffs on its exports in the
event of a No Deal you seem to be
somewhat behind government thinking on
this because just six days ago Michael
Gove the minister in charge of brexit
preparation said hi
EU tariffs on British exports remain the
biggest challenge in the No Deal indeed
but that gas 24 article 24 is basically
a two-page agreement between the EU and
the UK which the EU have got to agree to
why have they got to agree to it they
haven't got to agree to it but it to
make it work they've got to agree we
can't but you haven't got that agreement
you say it's a two-page we haven't but
so this is PI and we're not going to get
that agreement while the EU think
they're either going to get us to coerce
us to stay in the European Union and not
actually leave or to ask for an
extension or that we've signed the
withdrawal agreement which is better for
them they're not going to face the
consequences of no deal until we've
sorted out our Parliament if I were the
NY they're going to charge tariffs they
treat you as a third country and the
rules and tariffs apply at the EU
selling leaders and that and then the
day I'm remember you and if that's the
way the EU want to play it that's fine
it's unfortunate rules in that case then
we'll pocket we can refund all the
tariffs to our exporters and pocket 12
billion pounds a year from the European
Union in excess tariffs that's fine if
that's what the EU want to do that's not
what I'd like to do I would like to sign
gap 24 if we don't get to get a deal
which I don't think we're going to that
will give us 10 years up to 10 years of
tariffs and quotas free trade as we are
now while we thrash out that detailed
comprehensive free trade deal along the
lines of of the deal that the EU did
with Canada and we're far more important
than Canada will be 17 a market for 17%
of all EU and the deal will be far more
complicated and difficult to get let's
talk a bit about the situation of the
prime minister now because he's well
over 20 seats short of a working
majority
no power no authority and that's 26
double-up so it's 40 votes no
power no authority largest number of
defeats in Parliament for a new prime
minister
yeah these parliaments puppet the House
knee I would call an election can't run
down the clock a month no deal brexit my
analysis of the situation is that I've
always maintained that we are we have
got to remain dominated Parliament it
has always been like that situation what
actually has happened now is that with
the election of Boris Johnson by the
Conservative Party as the new Prime
Minister someone who is committed to get
us out of the European Union by the 31st
of October we've flushed out the
remainders who are in all the parties I
don't think I don't think it's any any
secret
we've now in the position where the loss
when you've lost major talent moderate
tell people that the father of the house
Ken Clark you've lost him you've lost
the number of people who are deeply
respected and had a lot of knowledge he
had a lot of experience of policies and
you threw them out which is hypocritical
in itself isn't it well because because
look at all the times that the current
front bench well I think that's that's
interesting voted against the reason my
vote she was proud I have voted against
the government on many occasions from
the back bench as you weren't thrown out
well I voted against issues and policies
I voted for the referendum I was one of
the rebels or that I voted against
intervention led the rebellion against
intervention in Syria some years ago I
voted against the hs2 project every time
it's come to the house high-speed rail
yet man I voted I voted against the
withdrawal agreement on all three
occasions but I voted against specific
specific policies what the rebels last
week did was they voted to take away the
government's ability to legislate and
hand it to the opposition and they were
warned prior to that vote that if they
did so they would lose the weapon let's
just look at that legislation for a
moment that the law now says that if
Boris Johnson doesn't get a deal by
October the 19th to ask the EU for the
usually you for an extension but is this
what you wanted a British Parliament
passing British laws with no
interference from the EU this is exactly
what you wanted was exerting its
sovereign Authority isn't it I wish I
wish that
well I'm not happy when Philip Hammond
one of the leading rebels on this former
Chancellor of the Exchequer Exchequer
only a few weeks ago he admitted in
conversation at number 10 with the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson that the EU zone
lawyers helped to draft that legislation
and that and the sting in the tail
doesn't matter who helped to draft it
does it well I think I think it says a
lot of whose interests that some of our
members are working and the sting in the
tail above it's still legislation and
apparently some people in your blood
don't believe he's bound by it well I
refuse Parliament's instructs well I
think I think it's against the
Constitution of our country we have a
system where more it's received Royal
Assent it is but the way it was the way
it was delivered doesn't matter
it's voted in its law it received Royal
Assent weeks on the statue we have a
cyst well I think it should be tested in
court we have a system where whereby the
the government of the day brings forward
legislation which the house either
approves or votes down it may be amended
and then it goes on the statute book and
at the next general action the
government will be held responsible for
the legislation it has passed we're now
in the perverse situation with the
connivance of john burke oh the speaker
we're in a situation where government
legislation is being passed on to the
statute book which the government
neither proposed indeed opposed it
doesn't run through a lot of laws on the
statute book that the government hasn't
proposed many of them wouldn't have
hundreds of laws I mean what are you
suggesting that he breaks the law and
I'm not suggesting that he breaks the
law because that but what I would say
what I lookee what I was it would set a
very dangerous precedent but I mean the
the the appetite democracy's appetite
for martyrs it is it is insatiable and
and you all need your brexit ears
appetite for mothers as well we had in
Duncan Smith former Tory leaders saying
the Prime Minister should be willing to
be and would be seen as a brexit martyr
so it's now it's something glorious to
break the law in Britain now a that
would do to Britain's international
reputation if the Prime Minister started
thrashing laws and trashing the rule of
law I think it was I think it would be a
retrograde step I'd rather take a legal
challenge to the law and I think and if
it go region at the region court after
that and they tell him to obey the law
well that they're the state then Supreme
Court says he should then he should but
there are other ways around it and
they've been well publicized he may
write other letters he may send a letter
saying he wants her he's been told to
ask for an extension to article 50 and
he may write outside that would look
really good he sends one letter saying
you can't do I can't do this no it's an
extension and the other one saying I
don't that makes a nonce he will never I
promise you one thing to him he will
never say I want an extension he may say
I have been commanded by Parliament to
ask for an extension however I think
there's no doubt he doesn't want an
extension and what will this extension
achieve what is another three months
going to achieve and the sting in the
tail of that legislation that was passed
helped be drafted by the European Union
she is it avoids a No Deal brexit with a
lot of people in this country don't he
who he who fights and runs away only
lives to run away another thing what's
gonna happen on 31st December and that
and the real stinger in the tail of that
legislation is in the final paragraph it
says that the Prime Minister is ordered
to ask for an extension to the 31st of
January three-month extension however if
the European Union will not accept the
31st of January and offer an alternative
date for extension that the Prime
Minister only has 20 or 48 hours to
accept that date what is to you was it
quick he's a quick thing what are your
most what if the European Union come
back say well we've had enough of this
we've had extension after extension
these short extensions the UK can't get
its act together five years and then
we've been a situation where probably
nearly nine years after the referendum
we haven't implemented the will of the
people's expressed that referendum
because you large blame the remain MPs
in Parliament for the mess Britain's in
you said last week democracy only works
when the losers accept the result and
they've gone against the will of the
British people I know it's always useful
to blame somebody else when things go
wrong but the fact is
if it hadn't been for the unbridgeable
divisions inside your party and the
three years that your party has wasted
bickering and fighting with itself the
will of the people would have been
delivered by now to reason May had a
deal
wasn't perfect but it would have
delivered brexit in name only
I'm not according to Jacob Riis mark I
would have given you your independence I
think I think you'd own the poles at the
time so people wanted it March 29th
YouGov poll leave voters wanted to see
that deal pass by 49% to 30%
conservative voters wanted it by an even
higher margin by 57% to 24% but you knew
better and your own interest realized as
they have through I I was price I would
suggest that the overwhelming majority
of those people had never actually read
the withdrawal agreements full never
even read the legal briefings on the
withdrawal agreement and they were
damning Teresa may was tasked to go and
they wanted a deal and they would rate
it and and and when when they saw the
deal they'd got it wouldn't have taken
very long at all before a huge amount of
dissatisfaction not then with the
European Union
who'd force the deal on Tereza May but
on us for voting for it and I promise
you - in whatever happens I am NOT
signing that withdrawal agreement I will
not betray my country or my electorate
because they haven't told me this and I
will not sign it if your party must not
in my name if your party had really been
interested in delivering the result of
the referendum Theresa May would have
recognized the differences amongst MPs
in Parliament and sought straight away
to work out a deal that could pass
through Parliament she had a majority
she briefly had some Authority she could
have started cross party talks
immediately but she waited two and a
half years before doing that it's your
failure you blame the remaining it's the
failure of your party and your
Conservative government I think tourism
a unfortunate will carry a lot of the
blame for this I never voted for her as
leader and I was actually the first MP
to say that she should go which was on
the Saturday after she launched the
checkers proposals when it was clear
that that was not delivering on our
manifest at leave a single market the
customs union jurisdiction European
quarters
take back control of our money our
borders at our laws and I'm disappointed
that we had an opportunity in December
of last year the vote of confidence
we're 200 of my colleagues did have
confidence in her so she stayed on I
don't know what they thought with things
going to get better we the clock has
been run down has been run down and left
Boris Johnson with very very few options
the clock was run down by brexit air
ministers who were in positions of
authority David Davis Liam Fox Michael
Gove Boris Johnson brexit supporting
ministers in key jobs and they failed to
get it done many of the people who are
now sitting on what they felt what David
Davis did fail to do is realize that
Theresa May was running parallel
negotiations through his own office
using his own civil servants and then
presented him two days before checkers
with a fait accompli that you're working
on a super Canada deal but this is what
we're going to get Davis didn't know the
first thing about the European Union
this is what he said within minutes of a
vote for brexit the CEOs of Mercedes BMW
VW and Audi will be knocking on Merkel's
door demanding there be no barriers to
the finish market it didn't happen I
think they said it was going to be the
easiest deal in history didn't come well
it should all the cards were gonna be in
Britain's hands didn't happen that this
was nonsense wasn't it project fantasy
know what we've what we've got is and we
do still have some semblance of
democracy in this country whereby people
who are dissatisfied to what the
government's doing come and Lobby me I
lobby the Prime Minister they'd love
with the Prime Minister directly due to
the democratic deficit in the European
Union we're trading with Germany France
and all the other EU countries but
they've given the powers of these
negotiations to another body called the
European Union and and it's what it
wants to get out of these negotiations
is going to be different to what our
customers in those countries want to get
and there is a huge Democratic deficit
meant that the people making the big
decisions in the European Union are not
elected and not it not politically
account
we just had the largest the largest
Democratic vote is for the European
Parliament yes a large 400 million
people a lot and the largest party
elected to that Parliament is the brexit
party and you're unhappy with her as
democracy for that's democracy is
democracy well I was I was very I was I
would have been very unhappy had we
pulled the Prime Minister then trees and
they pulled the European elections
because we weren't going to do very well
in them that would have been wrong and I
made that very clear
mr. Britain when you look around this
country you can't fail to see people
getting angrier more divided more bitter
demonstrations are getting angrier you
like it that way the country divided
full of hatred no affected no not at all
and but that's what you an existence to
a deal has produced isn't it no it's the
resistance to leaving as I said the
democracy only works you had a deal you
could have left you would have been out
but it was a very very bad deal and it
would if it was a deal I don't think we
ever would have got out of the back stop
I think that was the end state for that
the you've got in mind for our country
and they would have had a veto listen in
the article 50 process we can actually
leave while we're in it however long we
extend it and however unpopular it is
with our electorate once we'd sign that
withdrawal agreement the EU would have a
veto and when we could actually get out
of that treaty and I do think the
country can come back together but one
thing for sure Tim how is it going to
come back together when we lose Saudi
when we actually divide it when we
actually leave you have a situation now
where anyone who contradicts the
government line is belittled and
insulted you take the dr. David nickel
who contributed to the government's
contingency plan for a No Deal exit he
dared to share his concerns about the
government's inability to stockpile
medicines and he was told to be ashamed
of himself and he was fear-mongering he
was obviously good enough to contribute
to the government the suspect immune
working on this what a wonderful
precedent for a free society isn't it he
didn't tell you what you wanted to hear
so he was Fierman well I'll tell you
what is going on the the liberal elite
in this country have never lost a
serious political
battle in history he was their life
loyal they lots they've lost this one
and they'll use every liberal it at
their disposal to achieve what their
aims he's not leave the Europe he was
talking about people who might actually
lose their life because they haven't got
the medicines they need are you prepared
to risk lives in this ground project of
yours and that is a pure project fear
that continuously project for you what
these are experts who are pointing out
that there is a huge risk here my
question my question to you is are you
prepared to risk lives in this project
are you there is there is always simple
question yes or no well are the European
Union willing to risk asking you the
question we will cook a question to the
EU I'm asking you are you prepared to
risk lives we won't give me enough fear
that we are the second biggest
pharmaceutical industry in our country
and in the world only only bigger by
America and you get 36 a million packs
of medicine from the EU every well what
about so if it's so it's a big deal but
we say the questions we say his answer
the question are you prepared to risk
our lives not for this product I will do
I will do nothing that risks lives we
will not interfere with the massive
amount of drugs the manufacture in this
country that are used by people in the
continent we're not threatening their
lives it would appear that the EU are
threatening lives of people in my
country and I think that you have
misjudged the British characters that
they thought they're talking about white
wine non-friction Lestrade as Tim that
will result the day our measures that we
wear in the European you know D was up
we've got complete regulatory
equivalence with the European within the
European Union at one minute past 11:00
when we leave one minute past 11:00 when
we leave those goods were manufactured
while we're in the European what's the
difference between those Goods the the
minute before we left and the minute
after the day after worth what extra
checks would you like on those Goods
euros third country and you know that
we've already been through that is
actually got exactly full regulatory
equivalents it'll probably be a year or
18 months this is a common-sense
arrangement
illegal order so they give you what they
need on the good so legal order it's
illegal well on the WCA to think that
doesn't make it up on the who if at this
net aside was they've never been to
countries trading as third parties with
full regulatory equip this is unique in
history and the WTO rules is in the room
it's a non-tariff barrier but extra
checks what extra checks do you want
thanks very much is going so thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]